[Musique]
aujourd'hui à parler de la nouvelle
gopro la gopro heroes sept modèles black
et des chiens non demande très souvent
ce que monsieur gros tu achète toi même
ton matos est ce que tu l'achètes
directement et je vous réponds toujours
non j'étais absolument rien tous les
modèles ne sont envoyés par l'ema par
des partenaires - tout cas j'achète pas
oui sauf aujourd'hui je vais tester
différentes trottinette d'ici quelques
temps et pour ça il voit une caméra
d'action c'est compliqué de se ballader
quand j'avais 5 à la main en pilotant
une trottinette d'autant plus que la
semaine prochaine il fallait faire un
truc pour l'armée on sait pas trop où
exactement comment ça va se passer est
ce qu'il y aura des besoins d'actions en
mouvement encore quelques points
d'interrogation du coup j'ai opté pour
cette nouvelle gopro c'est la heroes
cette blague quand russell est le modèle
le plus haut de gamme de chez vos propre
on a une stabilisation de ouf
hyper smooth on peut faire des photos en
12 mégapixels on peut filmer jusqu en 4k
60 fps en 1080p à 240 images par seconde
on peut l'emmener sous l'eau jusqu'à 10
mètres ça c'est plutôt cool comme ça je
vous emmène en vacances avec moi aussi
on peut la commander à la voix on a un
écran tactile à l'arrière du hdr faire
du live streaming on a du super souvent
on a pas mal de choses et je me suis dit
quitte à acheter une gopro autant partir
sur ce qui se fait mais tout de suite
sauf que ça c'est bien mais lorsque vous
prenez des accessoires avec tout de
suite c'est très très cher 604 euros 96
centimes ça coûte une blinde
j'ai pas pris la gopro heroes cette
blague tout seul j'ai besoin
d'accessoire ça c'est un petit trépied
vous pouvez aussi la tenir à la main ça
c'est une sorte de père chante ça c'est
cool j'ai pris deux fois qu on appelle
ça la che semences pour la poser
directement sur la poitrine pour qu'on
ait une vue plus immersive pour tourner
les prochaines vidéos donc ça devrait
plutôt cool il nous faut forcément un
peu stockage j'ai pris une carte 64 giga
100 mégabits par seconde de samedi on va
servir parce que les commencent à
pleuvoir on à marseille pour le week-end
mais bon je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
l'impression que ça a déjà été ouvert
sas a déjà été ouverts ça ça bravo la
fnac vendez des produits neufs qui ont
déjà été ouverts ça je vous félicite pas
voilà vous avez une petite marque ce
truc a dû être acheté ramener voilà la
bête pour ça reste une grosse et
franchement format hyper hyper hyper
hyper compact on veut enlever cette
jolie fortune derrière bon là réside en
quelques instants le reste à l'intérieur
de la boîte qu'est ce qu'on a
autocollants gopro guide de démarrage
emplacement qui ça ça rouge
ensuite un taré
une fixation câble usb type c usb type
pas une fixation la batterie ce qui
coule sur ce modèle c'est que vous
pouvez remplacer la batterie elle vient
se positionner comme ça clac clac déjà
raide comme ça c'est assez bluffant
c'est plus lumineux que ce que je vois
avec nos propres yeux par écran tactile
accéléré vidéos photos large on peut
faire des photos aussi en gros ça c'est
énorme je peux mettre en 4k 1080p 60
images par seconde 120 images par
seconde 240 images par seconde
franchement il ya de quoi faire
stabilisation automatique faible
luminosité hockey franchement c'est très
intuitif les paramètres sont vraiment
cool peut nous faire des boucles vidéo
usb type c'est pour recharger hdmi pour
le mettre sur un moniteur ta carte micro
sd elle se met juste en dessous de la
batterie j'aurais tendance à dire pas
tremblé pour l'année ce qui n'est pas
mon cas
yes ensuite j'ai pris ça j'ai l'air
malin par contre un mais là pour le coup
c'est immersion complète c'est bien
serré que ça va le faire ensuite j ça
qui est l'espèce de pied trépied et qui
me sert aussi de perche à celle ci en
gros ouais ouais ça a l'air assez
robuste quand même je davis eyes est ce
dont je trouve vraiment la position que
je veux et ça me fait une grande perche
à celle ci pour ma go pro en fait ce
qu'on voit bien sur la boîte c'est qu'il
ya plein de configurations différentes
je peux le poser comme ça un peu
surélevé avec cette partie là peut le
poser directement sur le trépied je peux
utiliser ce pas mal de configuration ça
me sert aussi d'avoir sur une base de
pied de pouvoir monter en hauteur enfin
c'est pas mal trop le matos alors c'est
vraiment super lie recettes en tout cas
en la prenant comme ça à l'air d'être
juste assez incroyable j'ai vu plein de
vidéos dessus smar vraiment vraiment
vraiment motivés d'aller l'acheter par
contre ce que je reproche un peu à go
pro sa politique tarifaire autant sur
une caméra j'arrive à le comprendre
parce que vous avez vachement de
recherche et développement ça se
comprend en termes de positionnement je
trouve que c'est pas eu sinon l'aéro
cette écoute 430 euros
ça va c'est un budget mais pour avoir
cette qualité
franchement ça ne pose aucun problème
par contre je trouve que là où gopro est
vraiment très très cher c'est sur les
accessoires
salah j'en ai pour 70 euros et le
harnais j'en ai pour 45 euros ce qui
fait qu là rien qu'à ça je suis à 115
euros il faut c'est extrêmement cher il
vanne autres accessoires qui
m'intéressait pour la fixer directement
sur une trottinette
sauf qu'il fallait rajouter encore 60
euros
c'est bon là je peux m'acheter 200 euros
d'accessoires déjà 450 euros 2 go pro
mal à y ait un moment c'est un peu
compliqué donc faut vraiment faire son
choix
maintenant ce que je propose c'est qu'on
a vu que ségo pro on se passe quelques
images
et puis en quart de finale très
rapidement sur une prise en main peu
rapide que ça dit peut-être que plus
tard je vous ferai un test un peu plus
détaillée pour donner mon sentiment sur
cet eros est black
après l'avoir testé sur plusieurs jours
[Musique]
à turgot pouvoir vraiment fait un énorme
boulot pour tout ce qui va être
mouvement d'action vous la mettez sur un
vélo vous faites ce que vous voulez on a
quelque chose qui y perd smooth c'est
vraiment ça qui est cool parce que
effectivement lorsque vous êtes sur un
vélo à vtt
ça va bouger davantage là ça bouge ça
reste avec l'été par contre c'est quand
même hyper cool beaucoup plus agréable à
regarder et c'est pour ça que ce modèle
black est vraiment supérieure aux autres
modèles
il ya d'autres petites particularités
mais ça vraiment pour moi c'est vraiment
le gros gros gros focus de 7,07 blacks
pour l'artiste et je trouve franchement
franchement super cool destin peu rapide
donc dont je vous parlais un peu plus
sur le long terme quand j'aurai
davantage pris en main davantage tester
enfin non je pense que les options dans
son juste incroyable au niveau logiciel
ya un vrai boulot extraordinaire qui a
fait la stabilisation et les oufs issime
qualité des photos extraordinaires une
fois de plus qu'aux pros vraiment mis
une grande claque qui a vraiment senti
une go pro qui est vraiment d'une
excellente qualité
je ne peux vous la conseille d'ailleurs
si elle vous intéresse je vous ai mis un
lien en bas dans la description et puis
on va beaucoup beaucoup l'utiliser lors
de différents tests je vous dis dotant
d'une trop tiède pour se tester dès la
semaine prochaine dont je vous invite à
faire une seule chose pour suivre tous à
y voir un peu comment ça marche assez
vous abonner restez connectés comme ça
vous ne direz ce que vous en pensez vous
marquez tout ce que vous voulez
directement bao commentaires dites moi
ce que vous en pensez ce que vous avez 7
go pro eros est est ce que black black
edition s cadeau de ce mode eco pro vous
avez déjà acheté mark et moi tout ça
comme ça on discute ensemble merci soyez
sages et je vous embrasse
ciao